boa noite gente eu sou dessas mas bem
dessas ilustraria perfeitamente qualquer
matéria o jornal que convence com a
frase brasileira largou tudo para viajar
um sozinho quando a gente tem largada
ultimamente tudo para viajar o mundo né
mas eu percebi que nessa frase em uma
palavra que ainda incomoda sozinho
é como se fosse uma incógnita quando as
pessoas olham pra mim então eu tô aqui
vou explicar para vocês porque dois anos
recentes da minha vida quando viajando o
mundo sozinho por 40 países em cinco
continentes
quando tinha 35 anos de idade eu já
tinha 20 anos de carteira assinada
e aí eu comecei a achar que eu tinha
passado muito têm entre quatro paredes
quando resolvi me dá a oportunidade de
viajar o mundo
achei que a melhor forma de fazer aquilo
era sozinho é o meu objetivo maior é ver
os meus sonhos não os sonhos que tinham
sonhado pra mim para me livrar da
pressão social
por trás dessa mulher que ainda cidades
bancária de uma rotineira mas tem muito
mais que isso deve coisas só não viaja
descobri que era quando coloquei essa
mochila nas costas e vocês estão vendo
com uma mochila
eu via como a casa da mulher maravilha
foi assim que eu me sentir
assim que assistia na tv quando era
pequena e isso foi o que me levou mais
próximo ao meu sonho de criança viajar o
mundo
investimos em cubos
então eu vou pedir pra vocês eu vou
dedicar vocês alguns segundos de tex e
vou pedir pra vocês fecharem os olhos
fiquem tranquilos que não estuda hipnose
na minha viagem e durante esses segundos
você pensa em o que vocês queriam ser
quando criança e ainda acreditava super
heróis
estava conversando com minha mãe ontem e
ela me falou o seguinte quando tinha
três amigos eu arrancava todas as roupas
do armário e chegava numa mala e sai
arrastando aquela mala pela casa inteira
dizendo que eu ia viajar quando tinha
quatro anos ela estava mais voltando um
pouco de volta no armário e não tinha
mais o que fazer mas eu tava responder
as malas a ela pegou uma passagem que a
mesma tinha votado de são paulo me mais
velha assim forma ágil
você já pode passar paulo sozinho e
morava na praia grande
no auge da minha maturidade com quatro
anos de idade têm no chão e 3 desespero
comecei a chorar e resolvia de aquele
plano por mais alguns anos
aquela aquilo era apenas uma brincadeira
de criança
hoje eu acho que é um chamado dizem e
quando a gente vem pra terra
a gente tem muito mais claro que nós
vamos fazer aqui
quando a gente é criança depois que a
gente adulto
a gente acaba se esquecendo e se afasta
do nosso propósito
hoje eu acredito muito nisso e o que
leva bem da verdade do show já contém
algumas outras coisinhas pra vocês o que
me permitiu essa viagem nessa viagem
eu fui voluntário em hostel
eu fui voluntária num
um metro e setenta e oito totalmente
desengonçado
eu dancei num filme de bollywood na
índia
não vou falar em números
eu fui católica no filme santiago
eu fui budista em tempos remotos
eu fui indo em achas pelo mundo e mas
mais do que isso eu aprendi que ganha
asas não significa perder as raízes
mas o que leva uma pessoa a gato de
viajar o mundo ganhar na mega sena foi
no caso inclusive vem de muita coisa pra
tornar esse sonho realidade
a maioria das pessoas que eu conheci e
fizeram lembrar daquele filme the matrix
chegar um momento que não via mais
sentido na vida e de repente o assim
apareceu na vida delas
os pílula uma era o novo o outro era um
anti depressivo
talvez esse fosse o meu caminho não sei
eu optei pelo novo dá medo a gente na
minha mente não só quem está disposto a
isso tá disposto a enfrentar os medos
mas mais do que está disposto a conhecer
quais são os seus medos
eu jamais enfrentaria os medos que foi
feito nessa viagem dentro da minha zona
de conforto diz concursado 17 anos e um
dos meus medos maiores era ir ainda
todo mundo fala quem é super perigoso
pra mulher inteligente ou praia sozinha
não sei
já houve também o nosso maior medo é o
nosso maior desejo
hoje eu também acredito nisso é o
acúmulo nove meses viajando pela índia
eu trago no meu braço meu punho a
palavra amor tatuado em engraçadinha
quando fala a quantidade de países que
eu já fui as pessoas falam ah sim e
porque é que se fala tanto da índia é
bagunçada suja é desorganizado é a índia
tudo isso mas quando cheguei na índia
diante daquele caos
eu vi muita gente feliz e eu resolvi
ficar ali por um motivo pra entender
porque pessoas em situações tão adversas
estavam sorrindo muito mais do que
estava sorrindo ultimamente
e foi na índia
eu entendi a frase que a gente mais
relutante entender na sociedade atual
dinheiro não é felicidade e além de
quebrar os meus medos a gente amiga
muito mais que hoje leva mulheres para
visitar o país a se apaixonarem pela
índia como eu sabe do meu próximo vocal
e teve uma outra coisa que ainda me
ensino aqui no ocidente a gente é muito
boa lista a isso é bom isso é ruim é
feio é bonito
já começo até o fim na índia toda ciclo
pra começar e ele já tem logo de cara
bilhões de deus né milhares mas tem três
principais
um constrói o outro mantêm shiva esse da
foto destrói
quando cheguei na nossa cidade de shiva
e eu vi aquele burburinho falava com
essa galera e masoquismo como que a
cidade mais sagrada da índia só a cidade
de deus que destrói
peguei minha florzinha filas em pé na
beira do ganges e olhando aquilo
tentando entender até que o indulto
explicou
shiva que dá lugar a um novo pra algo
novo na sua vida algo que tem que ser
retirado e ainda olhando pro gantz eu
fiz um histórico de tudo o que tinha
passado pela minha vida que todo
sofrimento à toa que eu tive que o único
motivo daquela coisa sair na minha vida
por coisas melhores e em pó e na margem
do ganges o que é bem um ciclo de
sofrimento
um dos meus objetivos nessa viagem era
me desafiar em todos os indivíduos
a foto foi no nepal estava na beira de
um lago um dia peguei uma mochila
seis peças de roupa eu vou lá os
himalaias não vou ler
fui era pra ser três dias pioraram 10
eu saí daquela montanha e incentivo por
ford não feliz eu resolvi pé e ver de
perto nada mais nada menos do que o
everest
eu tô falando em escalar pra gente eu
tenho um pouquinho de emoção mas tem um
caminho que as pessoas normais podem
chegar mais próximo dele que chama campo
base e eu fui até o campo base do
everest caminhando dez dias sozinha
também tem noção não só tem um visual
incrível que quando eu olhei pra aquela
montanha
aí o campo base
o guia me falou assim sabia que o
everest é um nome novo dado em homenagem
ao homem não sabe como a gente chama
aqui e falou uma palavra impronunciável
playtime isso significa deusa mãe das
montanhas
eu comecei a tremer eu comecei a chorar
porque foi ali que eu descobri que ele
na verdade é que foi em frente àquela
deusa a deusa mãe das montanhas que eu
pedi força pra nunca mais desistir do
meu sonho
pelo simples fato de ser mulher apesar
das inúmeras vezes que eu escutei não
vai sozinha o mundo é perigoso pra você
é aquela montanha muito mais que isso e
dá oportunidade de ajudar mulheres a
descobrirem o mundo e foi impossível não
lembrar também naquele momento e toda a
minha trajetória do viário
isso inclui as mulheres que eu tinha
encontrado no himalaia e carregavam para
os fogos tão pesados que me fizeram
agradecer o qual leva na minha vida
eu lembrei também de outras mulheres que
cruzaram seu caminho
[Música]
mãe não me amar uma mãe no quênia uma
mãe na índia em comum o pedido de esmola
filhos no colo sorriso no rosto
costa que mais veio forte foi s
eu conheci um dia que eu fui fazer um
programa de índio só na adin e pelo
vietnã é índia mas eu peguei e coloquei
um sapato deve sair andando pelas
montanhas novamente chuva lama neblina
não sabe o caminho
eu olhei pra ela olhou pra mim ela vê a
gente não falava uma palavra com o
idioma
ela me ajudou em via de longe
olhava e já falava assim as mulheres no
convívio
só que eu e ela nos reconhecemos o
primeiro homem mulheres
a chuva não é capaz para nem a
tempestade detém os passos início todas
as mulheres têm esse ponto em comum
ela carregava nesta sexta eu a minha
mochila
mas não demorou muito para perceber que
a gente também carregava nas costas o
peso com um peso de uma sociedade que
cobra diferente mais que kobe
talvez por isso ela tenha três filhos e
eu três formações universitárias
eu cheguei a me perguntar aquela
reflexão e qual era um sonho dessas
mulheres que ao meu ver tinham nascido
em situações tão diz privilegiadas e meu
próprio pensamento respondeu
será que diz privilegiada não é você que
deixou de ver beleza da simplicidade e
eu vim aqui pra contar pra vocês a minha
experiência de viajar o mundo sozinho
mas essa altura já perceberam a gente
não viajam sozinhas mas que a gente
começa o agente pessoas incríveis eles
vão sorrir pra você pode fazer sorrir
vai ter um dia na sua vida que talvez
seu único compromisso seja fazer alguém
sorrir
uns e seus protetores seus amigos sua
família
quem sabe um novo amor vai ter um dia
que você vai e volta vai falar às dicas
com isso ninguém e que é isso aqui vai
ficar longe de pessoas estranhas mas
você vai dizer de parte mas até o dia de
dar adeus
e quando você for dar tchau o pedaço do
meu coração vai ficar com eles
só que o coração é uma coisa estranha
quanto mais pedaço da gente tá maior ele
fique
hoje eu tenho meu coração dividido em 90
países que eu chamo de casa
eu vou compartilhar com vocês rapidinho
das últimas missões algumas que eu
aprendi
prepare se
para quebrar esse preconceito e vergonha
deles não é dinheiro que move o viajante
que move o viajante é amor desapego
hoje eu posso ser tão feliz tomando
champanhe no caso de o boticário
quando eu posso ser feliz de cada um
está tomando água morna os cinco horas
torcendo por um ônibus passar aquela
mais confortável dormir na minha vida
foi assim na tailândia durante dez dias
uma esteira
a comida mais saborosa porque essas
crianças me ensinaram comer com a mão
o sorriso mais bonito que eu vi foi um
senhor sem dentes e apareceu quando
estava perdida no meio do caminho de
santiago
ele apareceu no meio nada olhou pra mim
e me deu a direção de sorrir e foi
sorriso mais bonito e desde então nunca
mais dúvida de que os juízes
o mundo é lindo
ele vai te mostrar tudo pelo fogo
mas mais do que isso ele pode mostrar o
que está dentro de você
eu costumo dizer que tem medo da morte
quem tem pendências com a vida
eu não tenho mais medo da ea por isso
amigos que eu falo pra vocês me
permitirem
vocês não precisam estar longe nem de
vata nem mas vocês precisam um dia que
seja
esquecer do passado não pensar no futuro
a experiência me trouxe hoje ao palco do
trf mas antes me levou para dentro de
mim onde eu tive a certeza que aquele
tudo na frase inicial não era nada perto
do que eu
é por isso que hoje a minha frase
preferida é de um viajante adaptação que
o viajante encontra pelas estradas da
vida viajar muitas pessoas pessoas mudam
elas te
[Aplausos]